All right, so the corporate media smear campaign
against Bernie Sanders has begun
and it's not only disgusting, but it's pretty
transparent as well. Just yesterday we were
talking about Bernie has taken the lead in
a key gold standard Iowa poll, the Des Moines
register poll, and here's how CNN spun it
and here's how MSNBC spun it and the smears
are now starting to ramp up and the big breaking
story from yesterday, the first week day after
Bernie did really well in that domain register
poll is that allegedly Bernie told Elizabeth
Warren in private nearly two years ago that
a woman can't win the 2020 president presidential
election. And Elizabeth Warren has now sort
of confirmed it and lo and behold, what a
coincidence. The story about this conversation
was broken by CNN yesterday and CNN just happens
to be hosting tonight's democratic presidential
debate. This is one of those really important
stories to dissect because there are actually
two, actually, there are really three stories
here and I'm not seeing anybody talk about
all of them.
So let's do that. Story number one is what
we knew would happen. I mean is Bernie's viability
as a possible democratic nominee became more
clear corporate media, which is in league
with the establishment would do more and more
to smear Bernie Sanders. It's happening. It
happened within hours of me going live with
that story yesterday. I don't actually think
we need to spend that much time on that story
today because we just did a bunch about it
yesterday. I think most of you understand
it. We just happened to report that it would
be happening rather than reporting about it
after the fact. I think we're all on the same
page as far as that story goes. Story number
two is whether the assertion is true, so let's
discuss that now. What are the facts that
are being alleged here? The claim is that
back in December of 2018 Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie Sanders who are friends met at
Elizabeth Warren's apartment in Washington,
D C they knew they'd likely be running against
each other to the end of the democratic presidential
campaign.
They reportedly agreed, let's be civil with
each other. Let's not attack each other. Let's
avoid hurting the progressive movement. Great.
Seems that that part is the agreed upon context
of this meeting. As the story was told to
CNN by four sources that they cite who I'll
talk about soon. Elizabeth Warren reportedly
said, Bernie, I think I can make a robust
argument about the economy. I think if I run,
I can earn broad support from women voters.
And Bernie Sanders responded that he does
not believe a woman can win. Presumably he
meant in 2020 running against incumbent Donald
Trump. So who are the sources? CNN sites,
four people, two people Elizabeth Warren spoke
with directly after the encounter to people
that are familiar with the meeting. That's
what CNN says. Three of those four sources
said that Elizabeth Warren told Bernie Sanders
she disagrees with his assessment, uh, that
a woman could not win.
So we were very quickly dealing with, is the
report accurate? Bernie Sanders denied that
the characterization of his statement is accurate.
I think that's important. And I'll explain
why when we get to part three of this story.
And then Elizabeth Warren put out a statement
yesterday saying that indeed, this is something
Bernie Sanders settle. Elizabeth Warren saying
Bernie and I met for more than two hours in
December of 2018 to discuss the 2020 election.
Our past work together and our shared goals,
beating Donald Trump, taking back our government
from the wealthy and well-connected and building
an economy that works for everyone. Among
the topics that came up was what would happen
if Democrats nominated a female candidate.
I thought a woman could win. He disagreed.
I have no interest in discussing this private
meeting any further because Bernie and I have
far more in common than our differences on
punditry.
I'm in this race to talk about how about what's
broken in the country and how to fix it. That's
what I'm going to continue to do. I know Bernie
is in the race for the same reason. We have
been friends and allies in this fight for
a long time and I have no doubt we will continue
to work together to defeat Donald Trump and
put our government on the side of the people.
So again, she says, we disagreed about whether
a woman could win, which gets us to layer
number three, which is the context here. The
story is being framed as Bernie simply saying,
women cannot be president. Do any of you believe
Bernie Sanders would say something equivalent
to a woman? Cannot be president of the United
States. Here is Bernie a long time ago saying
a woman can be president of the United States.
The real issue is not whether you are black
or white, whether you're a woman or a man.
In my view, a woman could be elected president
of the United States. The real issue is whose
side are you on? Are you on the side of work
is and poor people are, are you on the side
of big money and the corporations?
So aside from whether the assertions about
what was said are true, the real tragedy here
is that this is being portrayed as evidence
of Bernie's sexism or misogyny or whatever.
And it simply is not that. And if there's
a criticism of Elizabeth Warren here and there
is, it's that she in her statement, alludes
to the context but doesn't straight up say
the is not a sexist context. It's a disagreement
over whether in the political environment
in 2020 against Donald Trump, a female democratic
candidate could be president. Now, Bernie
could be wrong about that. Bernie Sanders
might be of the opinion that because of sexism
in the United States or because of how Donald
Trump has flouted norms when it comes to how
you're supposed to treat women, that Bernie
believes in 2020 sexism would cause a woman
to lose to Donald Trump. Now you can say it's
such a broad statement.
It doesn't make sense that any woman would
lose if it's the right woman. Women are so
different. It makes no sense to say no woman
could win. So you can say, I disagree with
what Bernie said and it sounds like that's
what Elizabeth Warren said to him, but to
say, Bernie is sexist. Even if he said it
absent any context is ridiculous. Let me give
an example. Imagine that. I said, I don't
think a Jewish person can be president in
2020 talking about Bernie Sanders, for example,
Bernie Sanders is a Jewish man. Is that antisemitic?
Of course not. If I believe that because of
anti-Jewish bias and antisemitism and the
rise of white nationalism, that a Jewish candidate
would be unable to win in 2020 that's not
antisemitic. Now, if I say Jews shouldn't
be president or no Jew could ever be president,
or Jews simply should never run because of
whatever, then we have something to talk about.
So if Bernie's analysis of the country at
the time as a woman couldn't win in 2020 that's
not sexist. Now I happen to disagree with
Bernie. I think many people could defeat Donald
Trump if they're the right people. They could
be men, they could be women. The implicit
smear of Bernie, if he said, this is where
this goes on the rail. So at some point, Elizabeth
Warren, if she does believe, cause remember
in her statement she says, Bernie and I basically
stand for the same things. We agree about
what needs to happen in this country. He thinks
a woman can't win. I think a woman can win.
She should actually clarify and say the discussion
was not a discussion that is an adjudication
of a woman in the role of the presidency.
It was a strategic opinion about given the
circumstances in the country, whether a woman
could or couldn't win Elizabeth Warren to
do the right thing and clarify that if that's
what she believes because she's playing coy,
she's confirming the story that is being used
to smear Bernie alluding to context that is
not a sexist contest context, but not saying
it.
So if you're asking me, should Elizabeth Warren
clarify that she absolutely should. When you
see endless conservative, say a woman shouldn't
be president, right? Uh, it's not an insane
thing to question. Could a woman win in 2020
the counterpoint of course is Hillary got
millions more votes than Trump in 2016 and
were it not for 77,000 votes? Three States
she would've won. So I just disagree with
Bernie's analysis, but that's all it is. If
Bernie said, I don't think women should run
for president. We are talking about something
very, very different. So let's step back now.
Okay. Consider what's going on here. Weeks
before the Iowa caucus, right after Bernie
takes the lead in Iowa, takes a lead in California
polling out of the blue. CNN just happens
to report, and Elizabeth Warren just so happens
to recall this two year old conversation being
couched as Bernie being sexist, which is completely
antithetical to everything Bernie Sanders
has fought for for the last 40 years.
So here's how it's going down. CNN published
the story yesterday and they, they just so
happen to be hosting tonight's democratic
presidential debate. What a coincidence. Every
minute during tonight's debate that is about
this, Bernie Warren thing helps Joe Biden.
The prediction is when this issue invariably
comes up tonight, Elizabeth Warren will refer
to Bernie as her friend and say that they
have a similar vision for what needs to happen
in the U S Bernie Sanders will say, of course
a woman can be president, but moderators will
keep going until they can generate something
more salacious after the debate. This spin
will be Bernie and Warren getting very chippy
there. While elder statesman Biden was presidential,
he was focused on policy and of course Biden
will be able to focus on policy tonight because
CNN won't bug him down with questions based
on this article they wrote about Bernie and
Warren, which will be used to justify questions
during the debate tonight.
So Bernie has been set up for an unwinnable
situation in tonight's debate. If he tries
to focus on the issues, he'll be accused of
dodging the questions about Elizabeth Warren
and sexism. If he buckles down and refutes
the attack and says, Elizabeth Warren should
clarify the context, was it strategic one,
not a sexist one. He will be accused of being
too mean in defending himself and if he doesn't
strongly defend himself, he'll be criticized
for not strongly defending himself against
the allegations I set a couple of weeks ago.
This election is going to be extra ugly and
I was mostly talking about the general. It's
quickly getting that way in the primary. This
is on day one where I said, I'm not going
to participate in the smears that can only
serve to divide the progressive movement and
prop up an establishment candidate like Joe
Biden. This is what we were talking about.
This is exactly what we were talking about.
So Elizabeth Warren, if she believes the context
was not a sexist one, she believes what Bernie
says, uh, has been saying for a long time
that a woman certainly can be president and
that this was a strategic discussion. She
should clarify it because otherwise she is
actually participating in dividing the movement.
And we should very clearly, uh, state that
absent context. This really doesn't tell us
very much one way or the other. And in the
end, this helps Joe Biden because remember,
if this hurts Bernie, imagine that this goes
shockingly well and it pulls three points
of support from Bernie Sanders. And imagine
that Elizabeth Warren gets all three of those
points, even though the polling tells us she
would really only get a third of any support
that is pulled away from Bernie. But imagine
that this cost Bernie three points and Warren
gains three points. Biden's still winning.
It still doesn't help Elizabeth Warren take
the lead and that's why this props up the
establishment right now, the leading establishment
candidate
is Joe bite. Tell me where you disagree. I'm
on Twitter at D Pacman. Follow me. The show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show, the David
Pakman show